how everybody my name is markiplier or a
Wilford Worf - ha ha ha ah I have no
excuse for wearing this other than I
wanted to and also I've got the mustache
glasses on - so whoa dude double
mustache what does it mean anyway I
thought I could be a little silly
because someone told me that the end of
the game was like right here and I
accidentally stopped it right before the
end but I always are supposed to know
that I like I played the game or watch
someone else play the game for you all
think you know what's best obviously who
do not know what is best
Wilfred Worf - nose was fast I also have
another secret key of which I am no good
dun dun dun
ok so that music which I remember being
an scp-432 was permeating through these
she locked with a simple mechanism
stories
i barricaded it for some reason maybe
because I locked this with a man and I
was slipping in and out of reality oh
please
very nice well is it not strange god
what have I done
what have you done oh hello hello guv um
hey wait a minute
what am I supposed to do here oh just to
get around
ah that's interesting it's actually
quite difficult because this this thing
is like it why that is not a normal guy
that is not a normal guy that is a
monster guy take that ha ha
you have disappeared I'm too proud to be
contained by the likes of you all right
what's in the closet
Anton yeah what oh hello where did you
come from dead body oh this doesn't
speak well for me Keith mansion Keith
okay
so the ending was obviously not a few
seconds away as you guys Justin it won't
budge then I guess I must leave does
this totally break the atmosphere of
this game I'm just curious if it does I
don't even care
it don't care it's too great I just love
it I love it too much
hello lately anybody home I still can't
use my lantern I don't even think I have
a lantern anymore hello is there a
secret door down here everything's still
a little bit blurry which does not help
my particular ah I don't know if this is
the same mansion that's why in
throughout the game I was slipping in
and out like there was when I was
slipping out there was an actual nice
mansion that could be seen but I'm not
sure if it's any better ah yes this is
what it was a various issue the pilgrim
is nearby then I'm here to be going
through the mansion again I don't want
to go into the pig room yes you have you
have indeed sir
wait a minute where's the kitchen the
pig room is nearby here let's go went on
I'm not gonna go there yet
hang on hope there's something there are
we God you guys said that that ending
was nearby but you obviously are all
liars and cheats yes we already went
through this you've already done this
before yes you have this is actually
another room where I appeared in so
apparently the world inside my mind is
much more involved I cannot leave says
who I am the master of this house
ah-ha
it's a squalor it's filled with filth
and rubbish la you see my letter of
recommendation for I am sick of serving
you you want to know why well why should
I be your maid when I'm more intelligent
than you lousy okay I'm the maid nod
master now please don't get into the
hole how can you be so certain you are
more intelligent me eat animals and I
don't proof enough what you're just cuz
you're a vegetarian what how dare are
you
I love me I love meat in my mouth I love
the way it explodes with juice in my
mouth I really really love meat and
everything about it I love meat all over
me I love to eat your kind to me you
know white meat a dark meat uh all kinds
of meat you know I love meat why does
these guys hate me Jesus just stupid
made me it's good for you does the body
good in it in your whatever way you can
whatever way you get that meat in yeah
it's okay with me yours just stupid and
ignorant huh yeah you never do any work
here the laziest person I ever met
I'll buy the toilet rocky blah blah blah
blah blah blah enjoy the rest your knife
papi browning Ruby summers Templeton
what a stupid name
I'll be sure to leave a handful of
kittens in your room for you to deal
with when I'm gone and I'll just take
the cue swatch with me
wait what you're storing my cats in the
hidden closet beneath my clothes what
that is strange that is very strange
okay so I got the relics what do I do
about that
I'll super rare item now just I'm
thinking about meat everything really
want some good meat right now I could
use some maybe a nice big sausage oh
yeah
that sounds pretty good no my mouth is
just watering at the thought of that
giant juicy sausage ah can't wait for
the flavor to blow in my mouth exploded
by that way what am I talking about
wait aa minute wait a minute okay how
long have I been here
uh huh am I your good boss no why am i
hugging through this dormant cuz you're
bored and have nothing else to do tell
me your handle yeah
what does this even do is just like the
self-destruct handle for the entire
house is this what's gonna happen
clean click and oh down Oh aha poifect
oh this is gonna be good this where I
store all the dead bodies probably old
stairwell my weak mind has failed me oh
this is where things get a little weird
again I'm pretty sure that this big
giant pink plushy moustache is taking
away from the atmosphere but I'm already
committed I'm doing it oh this doesn't
look good whatever is here what is that
what the hole in the wall
wait why do I need to go through the
hole in the wall up there wait a minute
hang on I can't
was that I can't Crouch I can't run
I see the truth it's sudden kind of
strong
it sounds like suicide I don't know I
gotta see what's in here first because
it could be something important you
never know at some wicked music going on
in the background there I do not like it
well done on finding the three hidden
relics the route served as merely a fun
way to thank my housemates who had put
up with me talking about making this
game for the last year he's from where a
relic lay represents my housemates
bedrooms in reality I made them as
similar as possible while still ensuring
they fitted into the setting the notes
within the rooms also characterize my
housemates the roomier Kirlian
represents my room again well done you
can only access from when you obtain all
the relics in a single playthrough yeah
good job Thomas yeah we're getting close
to the end here so good job everybody
this room is a giant mess good golly man
clean up your damn room ah Wharf TAS
doesn't appreciate the mess of this room
oh all right
we're about to hit the end of the game
here oh oh
hello what a lie what awaits me in this
room oh hello oh it's a noose I can't
even
I'm not even controlling it anymore
hahahahaha
oh come on man don't do it don't do it
Oh
ah
ah crap
oh is that blood seeping towards me oh
oh
this is not appropriate attire for a
suicide
and that's it all right that is the end
of this awesome custom story well done
look custom super awesome that was that
little rope yeah that's the rope yeah
okay awesome super awesome custom
credits so good job Thomas Q or God
Simon kion's God Lachlan summer Scott
William Simon Kyoto God
Lachlan summers yeah so anyway that was
really awesome click the link in the
description below sorry for the doing
this hahaha I couldn't help myself it
was given to me I had to wear it in a
game of course I did so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos it I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye
Oh
love
you